[Musique]
fabriquer du textile en France est aussi
le choix du slip français bonjour
Guillaume Gibaud bonjour Merci d'être la
fondateur du slip français on parlera de
votre business évidemment juste après
mais d'abord je vais vous faire réagir
sur ce nouvel étiquetage prévu par la
loi GIEC depuis le 1er janvier les
marques doivent afficher la provenance
de leurs produits et on se dit que c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour toutes les
entreprises comme vous du textile qui
produisent en France c'est évidemment
une bonne nouvelle ça montre la
complexité d'une filière quand on va du
fil jusqu'au produit fini on se rend
compte qu'il y a beaucoup d'étapes et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui un vêtement ça
plus vraiment de prix en fait on en
trouve à tous les prix à 5 euros à 10
euros à 100 euros et aujourd'hui je
pense que dans le contexte
macroéconomique qu'on vit l'enjeu c'est
de raconter un produit qui est fait
localement qui crée de la valeur
économique qui crée des emplois qui
créent la valeur sociale dans les
territoires et qui a évidemment un
impact carbone moindre puisqu'il est
fabriqué plus près cette étiquette
est-ce qu'elle va pousser ou c'est un
vœu pieux les marques à relocaliser en
France un doux rêve ou est-ce que ça
peut contribuer il y a une partie mais
elle fait partie de ce qu'on vit depuis
10 ans qui a été accéléré par le covid
évidemment de se dire il y a une prise
de conscience générale des consommateurs
prêts à acheter un peu plus cher pour un
produit de meilleure qualité fabriqué
plus près de chez eux on sait que le
made in France est 90% des gens qui sont
prêts à fabriquer acheter français mais
ils sont prêts à payer 10 à 15 % plus
cher donc on voit qu'il y a voilà il y a
un gap entre les deux et c'est vrai que
sont prêts à payer 10 à 15 % plus cher
alors que ça coûte en réalité plutôt 50
ou 70% plus cher donc il manque il
manque un bon morceau de pourcentage et
c'est vrai que du coup quand on arrive
avec un étiquetage obligatoire une
mesure du bilan carbone sur l'étiquette
c'est autant d'éléments qui font
progresser les gens vers un peu plus de
d'informations sur leur choix de voilà
de se dire qu'aujourd'hui un t-shirt qui
vaut 5 euros dans une grande enseigne
versus un t-shirt fabriqué entièrement
en France qui va valoir 35 euros le
bilan carbone n'est pas le même le bilan
carbone d'ailleurs c'est un t-shirt ça
va être 10 kg par t-shirt fabriqué
ailleurs un t-shirt made in France c'est
5 kg de CO2 donc voilà c'est parti short
ça peut être jusqu'à 5 kg des missions
en moins après il y a cette idée et
c'est que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
comment justement on résout l'équation
quand on interroge les gens ils sont
prêtés 10-15% plus cher mais ça coûte en
réalité un produit made in France en
textile 50% plus cher
ok il est meilleure qualité mais comment
on fait pour l'équation il y a
différentes choses il y a d'abord une
valeur d'usage de faire des produits qui
vont durer plus longtemps qu'on va
pouvoir réparer et puis après c'est un
argument marketing ou c'est vrai non ça
c'est vrai on le mesure on fait les
tests labos et on voit bien que et quand
on a visité les textiles en français
ailleurs on voit bien qu'il y a plus de
temps passé plus de savoir-faire dans un
produit fabriqué localement avec un
secteur du textile français qui est en
grande difficulté aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'acteurs risquent de mettre la clé sous
la porte aujourd'hui le contexte est
très compliqué pour vous deux trois
chiffres dans les années 90 il y avait
700 000 emplois textiles et habillement
en France voilà aujourd'hui ça c'est à
peu près une centaine de milliers donc
on a perdu 80 85 % des emplois en 30 ans
parce qu'on est parti fabriquer de plus
en plus loin pour de moins en moins cher
puisque le consommateur regardait pas
trop et puis voilà c'était pratique ça
fonctionnait très bien et puis il y a
des gens aussi bien voilà en Europe de
l'Est en Afrique du Nord en Asie qui ont
exception bien fait le boulot commercial
aussi pour aller attraper ses volumes là
donc aujourd'hui quand on voit que le
consommateur est prêt à nous suivre
comment est-ce qu'on peut
réindustrialiser s'appuyer sur des
marques comme la nôtre et aussi aussi
une nouvelle activité qu'on démarre sur
des acteurs plus importants qui soient à
la grande distribution puisque
aujourd'hui sont eux qui vendent le plus
de vêtements en France les marques de
luxe les marques de mode qui ont toutes
dans le contexte économique qu'on vit
actuel plus la loi Jacques qui arrive
elles ont toutes la préoccupation de
relocaliser de rapprocher une bonne
partie de leurs approvisionnements
certaines 3% d'autres 10% mais on est en
train de vivre se bousculer dans le
marché Guillaume Gibaud des vêtements
made in France vendus plus cher à vous
écouter c'est donc pas une fatalité il
faut investir dans des machines il faut
automatiser un maximum en même temps ça
veut dire moins d'emploi aussi il faut
il faut faire un peu de tout pour donner
l'ordre d'idées en France on met sur le
marché 3 milliards de vêtements par an
donc ça fait je crois que c'est quelque
chose comme 5000 pièces par minute donc
à la caisse de toutes les hypermarchés
de France et 5000 pièces minutes donc
c'est des volumes considérables on a
tous 10 kg de fringues dans nos armoires
donc déjà il faut
pas produire moins mais mieux vraiment
de se dire ok on va penser un produit
pour son usage si on met peut-être le
symbole des hivers ou le chauffage vient
peut-être à manquer je sais pas des une
polaire ou une doudoune de se dire ok on
va fabriquer ce produit en pensant à
l'usage d'arrêter de se dire qu'on va
mettre des paillettes des strass des
doubles manches et voilà revenir à
l'usage d'un vêtement pour fabriquer un
vêtement plus simple et là
l'industrialiser trouver le bon soutien
industriel pour industrialiser et
industrialiser ça va être automatisé
certaines parties la coupe par exemple
quand vous avez des rouleaux de tissu
bah vous l'automiser sur une machine
numérique avec voilà et avec un outil
français génial qui permet de gagner
beaucoup de temps de découpe et après
garder de l'agilité et donc du travail
de la main de l'emploi avec des gens
qu'on va former qui sont des métiers
manuels sur certaines opérations et être
en fait dans une agilité encore une fois
sur un produit dont on a pensé l'usage
où on va industrialiser on a toujours le
savoir-faire en France certains disent
qu'on a perdu nos compétences dans le
textile notre savoir-faire avec les
destructions de poste dont on a parlé
que notre appareil industriel et
sinistré avait dit on a perdu 80% des en
20 ans et ça c'est une vraie réalité
aujourd'hui il y a encore les voilà un
vrai bastion de résistant conçu voilà
s'adapter avec le temps moi je l'ai
vraiment vécu pendant l'épisode des
masques et du covid qui a été un élément
assez structurant pour notre filière on
l'a tous vu dans la presse un trou de
masque pas assez de masque voilà
catégorie catégorie 2 en tout cas la
filière textile française c'est mobilisé
dès le début du premier confinement pour
fabriquer des masques et à montrer au
grand public elle était capable en
quelques jours de mettre au point un
produit quand même assez technique avec
cette histoire de filtration
respirabilité tout ça et de fabriquer
des centaines de millions moi je j'ai
coordonné au sein du réseau façon de
faire donc j'étais le premier président
de la fabrication de 200 millions de
masques et 12 millions de blues et là on
a vu c'est des dizaines de milliers de
salariés qui sont revenus au boulot dans
des conditions voilà aujourd'hui si on a
un peu de recul mais à l'époque les
premiers jours du confinement c'était
quand même pas
et on a vu que cette filière était
capable du jour au lendemain de
fabriquer des volumes industriels par
milliers par centaines de milliers et de
se mettre en ordre de batailles sur un
produit assez complexe mais en tout cas
elle a la capacité de d'avancer derrière
il y a eu plein de relancer plus de 700
projets plan de relance du gouvernement
qui ont été déployés dans la filière
donc il y a l'innovation il y a des
nouvelles générations d'entrepreneurs
de relocaliser de plus en plus alors
tout ou partie de la chaîne de
production évidemment et nous l'enjeu
est moi le débat que je la vision que je
porte c'est de se dire on pourra pas
relocaliser 100% des productions
textiles à 24 mois ou même plus mais si
par contre on se dit on va chercher ne
serait-ce que 5% des volumes de
vêtements fabriqués en France et cela
leur localise à 24 mois là on
reconstruit sérieusement une filière
aujourd'hui c'est 3% des vêtements des 3
milliards de vêtements seulement 3% sont
fabriqués en France si on arrive à faire
passer ce chiffre de 3 à 5 à 18 mois on
sera tous déjà très content et ça nous
permet de voilà de renforcer les
entreprises existantes de remplir les
cartes de commande de mettre des
possibilités d'investissement en face et
je pense qu'on a de quoi redémarrer une
filière efficace merci beaucoup
Guillaume fondateur du slip français
merci à vous alors on l'a vu les marques
sont toujours à la recherche de nouveaux
matériaux toujours plus innovants et
Green focus sur une nouvelle matière qui
nous vient et oui de ne pas tu rage
[Musique]
fabriquer une robe avec du lait l'idée
sans le saugrenu pourtant c'est très
sérieux bonjour Émilie alors le Centre
national de l'économie laitière et le
centre européen des textiles innovants
sont en passe de réussir un pari assez
fou l'ancienne à partir de lait et oui
face à l'urgence climatique à la mode
recherche sans cesse des nouvelles
matières plus responsables et est l'un
des oreilles du côté de la nature alors
vous avez par exemple la toile
d'araignée qui pourrait devenir une
alternative à la soie la pomme qui
remplace déjà le cuir chez certaines
marques vegan on peut également citer le
pissenlit comme caoutchouc nouvelle
génération et donc aujourd'hui le lait
ou plus précisément la protéine de lait
qui s'appelle la caséine et l'idée n'est
pas nouvelle elle remonte à
l'entre-deux-guerres exactement alors
dans les années 30 un sinistre italien
[Musique]